that's not the plan
I was going to say um
you've had so many errors uh we can go
back to the ego trip to the YN era at
double XL I'll give you the exclusive I
think we're uh we're working on some
type of ego trip book to sort of like I
have the book of rap lists at my house
no no the book of all the magazines we
did oh okay let's go team magazines we
did uh like collectors of them have them
but we had the editor Dana alvarella
James
um she's trying to put together a whole
compilation kind of of that to show
people where it came from like those 13
magazines we put together like some of
the best articles and you know amazing
world's going to be together gives
people inside because that's the
foundation of my career for sure
independent magazine I did call ego trip
which again I got the book of rap lists
at my crib right now on my show
um you
kind of taking the source off the top of
the mountain during that double XL we
have to do kinda and might have see we
do these modifiers you like booty Kev
you like controversial statements say I
did yeah yeah and you and you had that
he might be one of the greatest well if
I'm not who is uh well you had them
stop talking with modifies we all do you
have them selling Eminem CDs to try to
that issue I just sucked your massario
it's all love BTS but I guess I wanted
to ask you like like that was a pretty
intense era of like hip-hop journalism
right but what was what was that going
up against them and then I think um on
my set
my set 50 Dre Eminem cover framed
because that is to me like well that was
the same week the same month they had
job we want to cover and there's a
poster inside of a guy breaking me in
half and then cutting Eminem's head off
so I mean it was crazy man it was like
you know and then you had Hip Hop Police
also following all of us too so that's
what made it exciting hip-hop police
were following you guys yeah like you
they would pull these dossiers and
everybody related to the culture was in
the files and they you know they tried
to impress me about that actually I
didn't know anything to not tell them
about right anybody's thing so I didn't
have to snitch because I actually didn't
know anything but you know they watched
all of us like if we were affiliated
with these artists at the time and the
controversy I had a foul 50 had a foul
Benzino had a file everybody had a file
so I was like you also had to realize
that that was one time I would say my
block was the most hectic block because
uh they built 40 40 club was connected
to the XXL building when they built it
when they built that [__] I was like oh
my God that's insane the club's a
capture that I was so mad I left half
day I was pissed I was like man The
Block is Hot over here hip-hop police
are gonna be waiting outside of 40 45
they're gonna see me this is how hot the
block is violate a Hitchman oh man same
block so Violet it has been 40 40 club
and double XL same block
crazy I feel like we've had not the best
year so far in terms of yeah we're not
number one yet right we haven't and I
also just feel like in general like
there hasn't been I like you because
you'll be a hip-hop's ass too like
you're that type of person my favorite
album of the year is Killer Mike and I
love the estate sale [__] those are the
two for me yeah yeah yeah those are good
but it has been a really light year
um what's your album of the year in the
middle of 2023. I wouldn't say I'm going
to you but I like those two years I also
like Gunner's album I also like uh you
like the gun album I like the gun album
okay I like the currency Jermaine Dupri
project the EP uh the uh Larry June
Alchemist album Alchemist is good I got
a good solid like top five to seven that
I like um I'm not picking another one
yet but I do think some big dogs will
come in obviously Drake's coming as you
see now with his little book poetry
scavengers
he has officially announced it but it
seems like I was gonna say like every
year bdot drops his list and then I
usually drop a list right after to like
you know be like how to do that support
but um I know like you guys
when you guys drop a Rap Radar interview
or a podcast it's always an interview
yeah I feel like once a year you you
should be on his ass for like an hour
going over that list
we can generate more bags man we gotta
you know to create we could do some like
when I see top five dead or alive show
everything Jada you know what I'm saying
Jade is coming he's not dead he's on
next oh okay okay well let's Elliot
kisses can we please do it along go
kisses here we gotta can we do the long
form
Brothers guys yeah hey man I appreciate
your time brother yeah